could be worse not that for me it's all
about perspective it's what you make of
it
All Things Considered I'm actually kind
of comfortable right now thank God for
shock I can be the kind of prisoner I
want to be still alive thank you right
mm-hmm
just two injured buddies yes mm-hmm
having a friendly convo while we're
waiting to get tortured again and you
know there's a kind of a positive in
having no options yeah because you know
we're not even gonna try to escape
because we don't we failed yes
tell you nothing don't miss the arm
really first of all Lefty okay so this
thing pretty much got in the way keep it
buddy do fools your suffering has just
wow that is a perfect summation of the
human condition
once you've embraced that you can do
anything bingo as you mean you love your
work and that kind of a positive
attitude quite frankly it's contagious
it is we'll see how positive you're
feeling after I cover your body in
gasoline and set you on fire
you know what it's amazing that you
would say that because I was just
thinking it's getting all chilly in here
huh thanks so much man what a dramatic
and fascinating man I think we owe him
big-time as do I really I mean all this
time away from my computer my phone my
work it's just I feel unplug yes yes oh
circle of life
Nozick Wayne yeah you know I can't
really feel anything anyway so you help
yourself buddy Oh what do you got there
this is what I'm gonna use to cut up
finally that's a great song I'm a
home-improvement guy and I know my sauce
and I gotta tell you they're cutting off
legs that is the way to go that's the
one that is definitely the one good on
you why are you doing this to me you're
making me crazy
whoa whoa whoa whoa somebody needs a day
off we of all people should know how
hard he works
[Music]
[Applause]